foreign
it doesn't have to be brief we have as
much time as we want but the different
origin stories
of this Brew called Ayahuasca which
exists in many different iterations used
by many many different tribal groups and
cultures at this point and churches also
syncretic religions at this point but
I'm wondering how you would explain the
development of this particular
combination of of plants and the reason
I ask is that I've heard many different
explanations for this so one is just
trial and error over a very long period
of time
another on the opposite end of the
spectrum would be
the plants told us
and I'm wondering how you would
explain the the arrival at this
combination of say Vine and DMT
containing a plant well first of all you
know one thing I mentioned about
Ayahuasca or Yahoo is that the the idea
we often have of it as we you know go
down to uh
the healers of the shapibo you know as
if it's sort of a quest for personal
Liberation personal well-being that's
always been there in the traditional use
of hallucinogens in South America you
know the the traditional syncretic Cult
of the cactus of the Four Winds and the
coronderos who use San Pedro cactus on
the coast and certainly the
popularization of Ayahuasca began with
the Yahoo letters between William
Burroughs right and Alan Ginsburg and it
was Burrows who turned up in Bogota goes
to the herbarium meets who he calls doc
Schindler who is schulte's and schulte's
sends them off and eventually gets gets
him
Ayahuasca in mccoa and on that road
between sibandoi and Moko in the upper
bhutamaya when I was there in the 1970s
there were already
you know individual healers sort of
working with the Gringo trade but also
working with individual campesinos
and of course in all of these healing
practices
the ideas that the imbalance of the
individual is treated through the
medicine and whether the imbalance is
caused by
bad health
poor finances personal problems whatever
it's a balance the source that one gets
to but I mentioned that only to stress
that it is completely a different
situation when you get into the heart of
the Northwest Amazon where presumably
these plants were were originated these
preparations so for example one of the
powerful
themes that is somewhat like what the
kogi do this idea that you know that
human beings aren't the problem we're
the solution because only through the
human imagination can The Wonder of the
natural world become manifest that that
we are the ones who have to maintain the
energetic flows of the universe we have
this proactive rules to play well in the
Northwest Amazon it's very much that way
I mean the the main origin myth that in
one way or another is shared by multiple
cultures speaks of a great journey from
the East up The Milk River in sacred
canoes
dragged by anaconda and in the canoes
are all the hierarchy the the Chiefs
wisdom keeper the dancers the Warriors
the slaves and also the three vital
plants Koka Yahoo and tobacco and these
are brought up the Milk River and
originally they were brought up by the
Iowa the four Thunders these
mythological culture Heroes and they
encountered a world of total devastation
and they turned that world upside down
and brought order to it by destroying
the negative forces so this idea that
humans are responsible for the
equilibrium and then the Iowa's went up
and became the stars and then the great
mother romikumu brought the people up
and the people settled each River and
because each River was settled by a
unique canoe each language group are
related to each other you can't marry
within your language so one of the
extraordinary things in North with
Amazon is
linguistic exogamy when you marry you
must marry someone who speaks a
different language
but the use of Ayahuasca is not
individualistic it's Collective at these
great ceremonies that go on for two and
three days where the individuals the men
all the people are there but only men
take
they go through two different kinds of
ritual
paraphernalia feather work
a day by night and they literally by
taking Ayahuasca don't become symbols of
the ancestors they become the ancestors
and they fly away to all the sacred
sites
to pay homage to
the natural world to maintain the
harmonic balance so the critical thing
here is that the use of the plant
preparation has nothing to do with any
individual's well-being but rather
becomes a prayer a ceremony for the
collective well-being and survival of
the culture and it becomes a mediator to
the Divine and so the kinds of things
you see in the kind of Gringo
Ayahuasca business around aquitos
is not traditional in that sense now as
to how this knowledge was discovered I
mean there are a couple possibilities
first of all there is a species of
maltigation's Vine diplateris Cabrera
which looks very much like Yahoo and
does have DMT in it so maybe they saw
that then they saw the opposite leaves
they saw the
psychotria coffee plant opposite leaves
clearly there's experimentation going on
but it's not just with Ayahuasca take
something like karari the remarkable
thing about kurari it's a muscle
relaxant but to affect the muscles it
has to get into the blood you can drink
as much karory as you want and if you
don't have some kind of wound in your
stomach you'll be fine but again how do
you how do you rationally explain that
process of elaboration you know and and
you mentioned trial and error well I
think statistically that is just exposed
as a meaningless euphemism now I
mentioned that story about Schultz is
saying you know the siona Sequoia and
the 17 varieties sync to you in a
different key well whatever that really
means when the people say the plants
teach us I'm quite prepared at this
point in my life to take them at their
word and the reason I say that is that
that these men largely men also women
but but in terms of Ayahuasca these
aren't
sort of random characters these are true
natural philosophers who understand that
Flora in ways that few scientists could
ever aspire to do they have spent their
lives in wisdom Traditions lineages that
have been taking all of this common
genius that I keep talking about we all
share as human beings and applying it to
that challenge I mean for example I mean
just jumping away for a second you know
when you go to Australia you realize
that the entire purpose of life is not
to change the world but to do the
rituals to keep the world just as it was
well imagine how much would be learned
if the people of New York City had spent
all of their existence putting all of
their energy and capacity into
understanding the biological
relationships of Central Park I mean
it'd be incredible right so so when we
say the plants teach us I'm not sure
what that means I don't quite know how
how it become operative but I do know
and I've had this experience myself
taking any number of psychoactive
substances that you have insights that
become
almost challenging to believe in the
wake of your experience yeah I never
understood the glory of photosynthesis I
never appreciated the miracle of this
verse of life this idea that you know
water can come together with carbon
dioxide and create the air that we
breathe and the food that we eat I mean
that's the poetic verse every child
should have to memorize and no
politician should ever be able to run
for office if they can't recite the
formula of photosynthesis and but the
point is I remember I took Kim and I
discovered a new species of San Pedro
cactus in 1974 in Bolivia and we took a
big walk of it on the Eastern side of
the Andes and knowing that it was safe
and you know Tim I mean schulte's used
to say Tim and I ate our way through
South America if anything back that had
a chance to get us High we would take it
it was coming we're crazy we're kids but
anyway we took this I took as Tim and I
made ready to say goodbye to each other
after over a year and a half traveling
together we took this extraordinary
parents would call heroic dose of this
new species we had found and we were up
for 48 hours and at one point we just
left the ground and we were like flying
over the surface of the Earth and I
looked down and I saw the Nazca Lines
you know and I became convinced that
that's how that explained how these guys
conceived those Monumental structures
but but at that same experience I saw
Tim fly up like acres to the Sun and
disappear and I knew right then he was
going to die and he would be dead in in
short order in fact from AIDS